hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge der kräftigen ideen erst mal sorry
dass das video heute zu spät kommt ich
hatte einfach den ganzen tag eigentlich
hatte ich zahlte keinen sinn wie soll
ich ein video gemacht deswegen habt
jetzt jetzt und ich würde mich freuen
wir ein bisschen mehr dran bleibt und
wir fahren an mit kräftigen ideen nummer
gamer spielt schreibt ein thermometer wo
wird man sehen kann wie heiß es ist
gleich ob sie gleich als idee gleich
drei mann theo de und ihr sieht jetzt
mal das crafting rezept eingeblendet
einfach oben links oben rechts eisenbach
und raiffeisenbanken in der mitte einen
diamanten die restlichen felder sind mit
obsidian gefüllt dann bekommen wir
dieses wunderschöne thermometer raus was
sich sogar so ein bisschen in diesen
farben da drin habe wie ein diamant mit
eisen und kälte diesen thermometer ist
es dann möglich in einer bestimmten
region einfach zuschauen wie für gratis
dort sind da fragt euch etwas bringt ist
dass das bringt beispielsweise wenn man
einen schneemann bauen möchte oder sogar
schneemänner überleben ja nur mit einem
bestimmten kälte grad beispielsweise in
der wüste erleben wir nicht oder auch in
regionen an der wüste daran kann es auch
schon mal sein dass er nicht überleben
das hatten wir schon mal auf ex folge
und dafür ist das thermometer gut und
ich finde es eigentlich ganz gute idee
man könnte allerdings an dem kräftigen
rezept noch ein bisschen feilen
irgendwie vielleicht mit einem
wassereimer und im jahr weil man mit
drin oder so weil so ist das ganze weil
sie nicht das könnte auch seinen sohn
chapman table seinen das rezept dafür
geld schreibt kräftige die taschenlampe
plus eisen helm gleichen leuchten also
solche wie bergarbeiter immer haben und
zwar habe ich da keinen kräftigen rezept
weil ich ja irgendwann in der letzten
oder vorletzten folge war es glaube ich
eine taschenlampe vorgestellt habe wie
man so eine taschenlampe bekommt die man
dann soll nach indem kann oder die man
halt immer an der rechten hand hat
beispielsweise gab es ein paar
vorschläge den kommentaren dafür
deswegen habe ich keine kräftige weil
man einfach diese taschen da habe ich
euch ja schon vorgestellt und eisen
hellem weiß jeder hinein geht dann diese
taschenlampe und eisenheim packt ins
treffen rezept bekommen so leicht helm
die man sich aussetzen kann dieser
minenarbeiter bergarbeiter dann hat man
immer seine taschenlampe vorne dran
finde ich eine richtig coole idee ich
finde es dann aber eigentlich ein
bisschen zu simpel das crafting
das rezept weil ich finde es sollte dann
schon auch irgendwie so ein bisschen
krasser sein als nur ein helm mit dieser
taschenlampe aber das ist ja erstmal nur
eine idee und das crafting die nummer
zwei jetzt komm crafting in die nummer 3
behrens cooler name der framerate finde
ich eigentlich rascher name etwas
richtig simples gebackenes brot einfach
ein brot in den ofen tun und man kriegt
eingepackt ein gebratenes brot oben
schreibt der gebackenes boden angebraten
report finde es immer ziemlich nervig
beziehungsweise unlogisch dass man aus
drei weizen im wort ein ford ich dass
ihr das jetzt denkt aber ich suche das
schon alles selber raus aber ich mir das
durch gelesen hatte habe ich halt nur
gesehen gebratenes gebackenes brot da
dachte okay gebackenes brot ist ein ganz
klar die idee aber dass er sich so oft
verschreibt naja hab ich hier meine
lampe ich finde es immer ziemlich nervig
war das hatten wir schon wieder sehen
ihr seht geraten chat crafting rezept
eingeblendet bzw eigentlich ein crafting
rezept ist einfach nur ein ofen und zwar
ist dort unten ein kohleblock drin eine
kohl und darüber hält das brot dann
bekommt man zum brot was ein bisschen
brauner ist das kult dann würde ich
sagen die fünf herzen auf oder so oder
vier oder soweit gebacken ist und das
kann man einfach in den ofen reintun
dann hat man ein gebackenes brot und
kein gebratenes brot ist eine ganz
interessante idee die recht simpel ist
aber ich finde ja allgemein ich bin ein
befürworter dafür dass man in minecraft
mehr dinge essen sollte also in letzter
zeit sind natürlich auch schon ein paar
sachen hinzugekommen wie mehr samen und
was alles keine ahnung was willst du
denn jetzt noch karotten kartoffeln so
was in die richtung aber das finde auf
jeden fall richtig cool und brote sind
simple sache finde ich ganz cool und
jetzt kommt auch schukraft die nummer
vier
hallo conny wie wäre es mit einem besen
als wenn man ein haus baut und die dort
lebt sammelt sich auf dem boden staub
oder dreck um mit dem besen kann man ist
dann wie die armut einem klick auf den
boden entfernen armut ich glaub er
meinte armor weil bei der armee ist auf
bildung muss man dafür rechts liegt
rücken wenn man dinge nach etwas
angezogen dann hat er mir jedenfalls das
rezept geschickt und dann hatte aber der
gast 6 ab dem der us soldiers text
geschrieben an sich gut aber der besen
hat mehrere borst und dann hatte das
geschriebene zu reden allerdings finde
ich mit fäden seinen besen zu machen das
ganze wissen
nichts weil deswegen seht ihr jetzt mal
das crafting rezept eingeblendet
deswegen habe ich das ein bisschen
modifiziert und da sondern seinen besen
ross macht wenig einfach viel viel
besser fände und zwar ist dann einfach
so weizen dran um zwei sticks und
bekommt man so eine art besen und ich
finde der sieht doch endlich coole aus
es kam noch besser darstellt mit zu
komischen fäden dran
und damit ist dann einfach so wenn man
länger in dem raum nicht wahr
beispielsweise im keller oder so desto
tiefer man ist desto mehr staub sammelt
sich an beispielsweise muss man das dann
auch alles einfach putzen regelmäßig
geht eigentlich recht schnell wenn man
einfach noch rechtzeitig auf dem boden
machen muss man hat eine riesige fabrik
in der man lebt aber ich find's ganz
interessant und natürlich geht minecraft
gerade dann wenn sie etwas hinzugefügt
wird mehr in die richtung von wegen
dann machen wir noch dies und das und
hat vier kinder in minecraft lebt nicht
mehr minecraft sein werden viele sagen
aber ich finde es ist eine coole idee ob
man will das essen zugeführt wird es was
anderes aber es geht hier um die ideen
und nicht um die umsetzung solcher
sachen coni hat einen kräftigen dvd ich
am computer
damit man in minecraft ich per internet
daten kaufen kann zum beispiel ein stück
holz für 30 märkte eisen glas redstone
ich hoffe es gefällt dir ja es gefällt
mir sehr gut hier seht jetzt mal das
crafting rezept eingeblendet und zwar
einfach linke seite allen rechten seite
reisen
unten in der mitte ein redstone und
darüber zwei glas bekommt man diesen
computer habe ich jetzt einfach diesen
computer aus computer kraft genommen ich
weiß freunde es gibt zu allen möglichen
sachen die ich mir vorstelle schon
irgendeinem ort aber es gibt zu allem
irgendeinem ort und ich stelle ja
teilweise sogar sachen spots vor sind ja
einfach kräftigen ideen dies in vanilla
geben sollte dieser computer stellt dann
quasi einfach sonnenbrille job für
zuhause da mehr oder weniger also man
kann damit einfach sich so angebote
anschauen vielleicht mal gibt so sale
sachen dann sparst du so wenn du einen
diamanten willst musst du nicht 20 leder
gehen sondern nur noch 10 und oder kann
man sich richtig coole sachen mit einem
fall das empfinde das ist auf jeden fall
kräftig idee nummer 10 nummer ziehen das
ist kraft die nummer 5 in wir bei
zählern kommen dann wird die folge den
rahmen sprengen
aber ich finde ja die idee eigentlich an
sich ganz cool es gibt schon unendlich
viele redstone sachen computer
hinzufügen und dies und das aber so
einen richtigen kleinen computer gibt es
halt noch nicht immer aircraft wandel
und das extrem cool
das macht minecraft kaputt das gibt
schon am ort ja ich weiß wenn man so
etwas nicht mag solche serie nie sowas
vorstellen dann sieht man sich den
dass alle möglichen sachen dabei aber
ich möchte euch einfach sagen bitte geht
respektvoll miteinander um nicht in den
kommentaren andere leute beleidigen auch
wenn die sowas schreiben ich meine
stimmt ja sowas gibts halt schon enorm
aber trotzdem ist die kräftigen idee so
ne von wegen
deswegen verstehe auch nicht warum er
den fake sich viele leute bestanden das
kannte ich schon das darfst du nicht
vorstellen ja aber ambri kennt noch
nicht und das ist ja auch eigentlich
egal weil ich mache das weil es mir spaß
macht und das habe ich hier schon wieder
das was mit dem video ich habe mich
gefreut dass sie bis zum ende dran
geblieben war
seit tun ich würde mich über eine
bewertung freuen seit tun
wir sind beim nächsten mal wieder seit
tun